welcome back to CBS mornings you know
that Black Friday has long been The
Unofficial kickoff to the holiday
shopping season you know that Tony I do
know that you know that I know that I
know that we all know that holiday sales
are expected to hit at least
942 billion dollars we'll see this year
yep that's up six percent from last year
but with online shopping and earlier
sales does Black Friday still hold the
same power as in the past some people
think so Nancy Chen is looking into that
very thing for us Nancy good morning
very good to have you in the studio
can't wait to see what you found out Ms
Jen hey good morning good to see you
guys Black Friday is by definition
supposed to be the Friday after
Thanksgiving right but we've been
spotting Black Friday sales weeks in
advance this year still whether it's the
day or the whole month there are good
Bargains to be found this year
especially
three two one
overnight weights doorbuster deals and
sometimes more than just a few sharp
elbows
[Applause]
a beloved custom for some the day others
avoid at all costs for decades few
Traditions have kicked off the holiday
season quite like this to me Black
Friday means Stress and Anxiety and
crowds what's so fun about Black Friday
it's a kind of like atmosphere an
estimated 115 million people are
planning to shop in stores and online
the day after Thanksgiving this year
compared to 64 million on Cyber Monday
but even while it continues to be the
most popular shopping day Black Friday
as we know it may never be the same is
Black Friday Dead Black Friday is not
dead it's just changing a lot Kristen
Gaul is the president of Rocket 10
rewards a cashback app that partners
with thousands of retailers Black Friday
is supposed to be the Friday after
Thanksgiving why are we seeing deals Now
consumer shopping has changed
significantly since the pandemic a lot
fewer of us are willing to to go to the
stores on Black Friday and battle people
and use our elbows that retailers are
more willing to allow us to shop over a
longer period of time excess inventory
left over from the pandemic is also
moving up those holiday sales there are
always discounts Bargains and sales
during this time but I think it's going
to be more aggressive than ever before
because they are trying to move that
inventory out correct they don't have
space in their warehouses they're going
to lower prices on everything that
includes the Outdoor Outfitters REI
which started pulling back from Black
Friday itself in 2015 when it closed its
doors shocking the retail industry this
year the company announced the move will
be permanent how would you describe
Black Friday well prior to 2015 I would
have described it as a bit crazy we met
REI president and see Eric Arts at the
company's flagship store in Seattle as
Black Friday dead well it's certainly
dead at REI you're essentially taking
the day off what does that mean for your
bottom line our business has thrived in
2021 inclusive of Black Friday actions
we posted a record year in both sales
and profits it's a testament to the fact
that putting your purpose in your people
first putting it ahead of your profits
the profits will come in due course
Target Macy's
and will follow suit and recent years by
closing on another once major shopping
day Thanksgiving but still want in on
the Black Friday action even as many
stay home your approach to Black Friday
this year is
let's see let's see what happens
given all that the question is when
should you do your shopping if you're
willing to play the game a little bit a
lot of retailers will discount further
into the holiday season if they do not
have a good Black Friday so there could
be some great deals to be had closer to
Christmas but if it's an item you really
really want go for it on Black Friday
itself or be like me and go ahead and
start shopping a week in advance if you
don't go for it I mean it could be sold
out right yes that's at that price point
that's the risk all right I'm in the
market for a TV oh those deals outside
right size no larger than 55 inches
according to the experts given the
dimensions of the room because you don't
want it to be like front row at the
movie theater where you're like right
yeah
I like a big TV that's a big TV Tony
I'll look out I'm gonna advocate for a
little smaller than that but we'll see
yeah let me know I appreciate it all
right Nancy thank you very much